Dragon Ball Z resurrection F a new
Dragon Ball Z movie in limited
theatrical run this is an amazing time
for Dragon Ball Z fans as some of you
may know I grew up with Dragon Ball Z
I've always loved Dragon Ball Z and the
frieza saga has always been my favorite
saga so I was really excited to find out
that Frieza was going to be resurrected
for this movie so in this film Frieza
gets revived by the Dragon Balls so you
may be thinking but since then they've
already defeated people like the
androids and cell and majin buu so why
does Frieza have a chance this film
explains it by saying that never in his
entire lifetime did Frieza ever attempt
to train or get stronger because he was
always stronger than everyone else so in
this film they give him a few months to
Train and in that time he gets stronger
and is now worthy opponent for Goku who
has also made some advancements of his
own last year the film battle of gods
came out and I had a really good time
with that movie I loved it a lot more
things I loved about it was how
unconventional it was for your
stereotypical Dragon Ball Z even as a
fan I recognized the cliches in Dragon
Ball Z Goku always has to win there
always has to be like these big epic
fights and I liked how battle of gods
subverted that and gave us a less
conventional Dragon Ball Z movie
especially with the ending of that film
resurrection F is far more of a
fanservice Dragon Ball Z film they've
resurrected everyone's fan favorite
villain in my experience there are two
different types of Dragon Ball Z fans
there's the fans who just want to see
people getting punched in the face and
action and exciting fun fight sequences
and then there's the fans that want that
but they also care more about the story
and the characters and getting little
beats right I think those fans are the
ones that love battle of gods the ones
who just wanted to see action and wanted
to see Goku punch something in the face
we're more disappointed with that film
and those fans are going to like
resurrection F more because this film
definitely focuses more on the action
it's a lot of Goku vs. Frieza
punching each other and it's awesome the
animation is fantastic the fight
sequences are vivid with excellent
choreography it all looks amazing but
the story and the characters isn't as
strong as it was in the last film and
certainly not as strong as it was in the
show and that aspect of this movie
disappointed me I'm not going to sit
here and fanboy over Dragon Ball
despite the fact that you may have
thought I was going to because that's
not the kind of person I am I love
Dragon Ball Z and I really enjoyed this
movie and I had fun with it but it was a
bit disappointing for me for a few
reasons for one certain characters in
this film simply do things that don't
make sense Master Roshi fighting freezes
army doesn't make sense he's not that
strong it's cool to see him there I love
that character it just doesn't really
make sense in the storyline because I
know Master Roshi isn't that strong he's
just there because fanservice also this
movie continues the unfortunate string
of events that has led Gohan one of my
all-time favorite characters in the
entire show to be the most nerfed
unnecessary side character that gets his
ass kicked easily he has one awesome
moment and then he's just tossed to the
side once again to focus on Goku being
awesome Frieza was back which is awesome
he's my favorite villain trust me I got
chills watching Goku and Frieza fight
again the fights extremely satisfying
however the first 20 minutes of this
movie are very slow the extended edition
of battle of gods on blu-ray had a lot
of scenes that were removed from the
theatrical about 20 minutes of them it
almost felt like resurrection F had more
of those deleted scenes except they
weren't deleted they were included and
so it was longer and it felt like there
was a lot more baggage that didn't need
to be there in those first 20 minutes
still though this movie was really funny
Akira Toriyama signature humor is
prevalent throughout this entire thing
lots of off-color strange weird humor
and it just works it's very funny the
characters are also well realized for
the most part particularly Vegeta and
Goku still have amazing banter with one
another
watching them argue and watching Vegeta
get all huffy and upset is great Goku's
hilarious I love Goku piccolo got more
chances to shine in this movie than he
did in battle of gods which was very
satisfying for me as did krillin and
tien it was great to see tien kicking
ass again there was more respect given
to some of those characters but i just
hate how they continue to pound go on
into the ground until he's just like
this guy in a tracksuit wearing glasses
and he's just not go on anymore he was
so cool nacelle saga this movie also
introduced a new character named Jocko
that I really liked he was like this
intergalactic policeman of sorts he was
extremely funny very entertaining and he
also had some butt-kicking skills of his
own
really like that new character one of
the things I'm really pleased with this
film and battle of gods that they're
introducing new characters that aren't
annoying that are actually very
entertaining they brought back beerus
and we see in this film my biggest issue
with this movie though is unfortunately
the ending and don't worry i will not
spoil it for you don't worry about that
you guys know me the ending is sort of
leading you into this possibility and
you're like oh man that could be awesome
that would be like that would just make
sense like in the show and the history
and it was yes dude oh you did that okay
the film pulls are really cheap maneuver
in the last five minutes that didn't
work for me it was leaving us something
really epic and very powerful and very
different and they went the safe route
and that bugged me but there's something
to be said about Dragonball Z and I
think it's very important you see when
Dragon Ball Z reached popularity I was a
kid I was like eleven twelve I was so
into it I thought it was great most
people in this theater were my age in
their 20s to early 30s but Dragonball Z
was about was always extreme optimism
you can be the best at what you want to
do you can work for your goals you can
obtain them nothing can bring you down
when we were kids it was a lot easier to
buy into that now we're older and the
cynicism and pessimism of the world has
started to seep into us so it's a little
harder for us to peer back into that
world and accept that extreme optimism
that Dragon Ball Z is still preaching to
this day and I got to commend them for
that because it's harder for us now to
go back to that place and I have to
remember that when I watched
resurrection F despite the fact that
this movie is asking me to just have fun
and enjoy myself there is a part of me
that wants to be like no I'm an adult
and then I'm like wait what am i doing
this is Dragon Ball Z and I get to watch
it in a theater how cool is this
and I think there is something to be
said about the fact that most of the
fans now are older and there's certain
things we're expecting now and I think
we're expecting Dragon Ball Z to change
a little bit and become a little bit
more like how we work now even though
it's still working on that level that we
liked it on and we were like 13 now that
we're in our 20s and 30s I think we need
a little more
eat in the next film and I hope they
give that to us still I had a great time
watching this movie the action was fun
it was fast paced entertaining it was
very funny there was some new characters
I liked there were just certain elements
in regards to the ending especially and
the storyline leading up to said ending
that just didn't work for me it wasn't
as interesting as battle of gods it was
a more conventional and safe Dragon Ball
Z film that sometimes came off more as
fanservice and less of a brand-new story
like battle of gods was I still had a
good time with this movie though and if
you are a die-hard Dragon Ball Z fan
like I am I think you'll agree with me
when I give Dragon Ball Z resurrection F
of B so guys if you do see the film let
me know what your thoughts are below
it's currently in a limited theatrical
run between August 4th and August 12 go
see it if you'd like to and as always
thank you so much for watching and if
you like this you can click right here
and get stuck my nice